ragazzi ma perché vedi che adesso starà
iniziando a prendere la tua temperatura
cammino per milano sono sei e mezza è
ancora notte che sta andando a fare il
papà per la prima volta il web decise di
guardì di concedermi questo prestito i
loro figli
personalmente non ho un problema con i
bambini diciamo che li odio
io ho il terrore di ucciderli
involontariamente anche volontariamente
mi stanno facendo aspettare sotto casa
da un po e io ho il terrore che stanno
tramando qualcosa perché allora devi
svegliare gesù e cambiare livia
preparare la colazione portando la sigla
è facile gesù è quello di sesso maschile
o dire quella dei sessi fini rivelerò
beh però i nostri figli sono degli
incivili te lo posso dire con tanto di
pisani stato sofia era vivo io non me
maneggiato un bambino è come se milan e
samsung radioso nostro figlio non ci
sveglia saldo del proprio tabù su papa
gesù ma alcuni cani nella stessa cosa
[Musica]
non parlo i bambini se vogliamo fare
colazione di gesù è la pappa mi sta
dicendo benissimo se ci sentiamo qui che
cosa mangiamo latte no no no ma non è la
maggior parte l'attuale 10 l'arte di
amore che saper mangiare la pappa giallo
la pappa gialla c'è una giustizia che
rimane qualche regalo come che si chiama
gino gino il castorino ora non
appoggiarla quando te lo dico che quelle
rare tutte luci del cane sarà la tappa
gialli per piquè verbali già la maionese
e confermando il nostro sito mangia la
fortuna diciamo questa ma in questa lui
mangia anche da solo ha però una lei
vogliamo uscire entro la tendenza ok
devo dimostrarlo per essere amici ma per
me non piace dire lo sai luogo ai
maestri a tutte le chat e le ferite ma
chiamare mamma mia la fatina la fatica
i ricavati effettivi 57 perché abbiamo
nato a cagliari per un antiossidante che
se fossi la tua 2000 due anni luca t non
si affiderà mai vi diamo la compagna
cariccio abbiamo della bavaria
investiamo krazia segnerà adesso quanto
trecate vogliamo mangiare una pappa
buonissima giosuè questo temperato ha
gridato spider man per forse non avevo
se riusciamo a creare di cucchiaio
spider man
l'unica richiesta che ti faccio e non
fare cose che poi dovrò ripetere tutte
le mattine roccantonio urla bravo come
se fossi dal dentista rai ci mettiamo
per terra giocare ok spazio in piedi
grande a camminare sono le otto eventi
ok d'oca che tagliare tagliare allora
lavado natale poi signore che è entrato
in casa con la barba che si spaccia per
tuo padre è in bagno che sta caricando
la siringa
abbiamo una notizia da casa è arrivato
il momento di questo appena vedrà questa
inizierà a urlare tantissimo
da questo punto in poi lui diventa
taglierà ti sentirai sul butter
prevedere per il web peider man è
diventato spider man con un lavaggio
nasale o occupati di tenerlo fermo la
testa aspettano la posso dovrebbe
toccare a kakà gio ponti mista jose
questo è il tuo odore di solito se un
hotel come come come com'è che che è
diventato il cane un cane guarda che i
bambini se non fanno a kakà diventano
cani al como ragno è così così lungo
come volt perché fa la cacca alle scelte
che la trattiene medico tuttavia e tutti
quei essere già unico all'uomo ragno
questo no e penso che mi mette insieme a
seguito di un po da allora abbiamo fatto
inizia a pulire un po con i controlli
bravissimo ma dura giusto è un talento e
dove le mettiamo un po di pasta o di
pasta tipo siano gli strappi niero
davanti vero così lei così benissimo
quante volte al giorno questo 45 ok
vestiti puliti andiamo a scuola questo
piede
sono lavori sono state dedicate alla
fiera per giù le mani
vabbè santifichiamo un pochino tutto
come come capita ok ok amore è pazzesco
la festa in casa con le scarpe va bene
niente live a quelle che fa sul tavolo è
tutto a posto poi uno un pettegole
scarpe o sia stato un tutorial per
spiegare a tutti quanti contrada sento
unire ovviamente soluzione valida no e
guglielmo tuo figlio sto scappando
[Musica]
kgb express 2
pronto
sì sì glielo messo allora presidente che
ha messo un pochino più futuro amore
tranquilla scacchista ok ti mando ti
mando una foto tranquilla gioco perfetto
cioè ci può stare muoviti che si è
svegliata only oddio ma torniamo a casa
che cosa ok ma perché verso si allatta
dove non celata da sdraiato un bambino
ma cosa state perché non ti potrai arene
località non ho il bambino come deve
stare e orizzontale hashtag no no tipo
tipo tornei slash ok ti doti da rollo mi
sono tirato un po di latte se sì come o
liga non è abituata a prendere biberon
il rischio appunto per si accorge che
non c'è la mamma c'è sole mio green
screen gossiparo 28 scusava questo
sottili addosso un po si prendono la
stessa temperatura del corpo e non è il
regalo che a sto punto
in questo modo si all'ansia del gender
capitolo attento al braccio a braccio di
a un braccio anche 10 cuscino
d'allattamento conoscere questa
maneggiare una tipica non c'è niente da
dire che per cercare
ha smentito che il mio seno ok questa
ricchiari i tavoli sono in contrario ma
no visto che la patatina e delicata va
lavata nel lavandino sono non è kakà
questo questo è un mese grande olivian
se la meglio di quelle di olivia ieri
sera l'ho messa una fascia avevo paura
che lei fosse tutto un segno del cranio
andrea ancora la fontanella aperta
allora se belli se però dobbiamo
muoverci abbiamo un appuntamento sono
riuscito a invertire capito ho imparato
a essere un padre possa avere una cosa
cui intanto che io finisca dimensioni e
prepara la borsa senti ma oggi cosa che
ti serve esattamente visto che stiamo
fuori un pochino più del solo allora
serve secondo me però dopo ok non ho
ancora trovato anche video riga quanti
ne prendono poi si possono bastare
secondo te con quali manca altro ma
anche olivia
[Musica]
così facendo da diversi anni due cui una
bambina allora la tua mattinata da neo
papà è finita io mi sentirei di darti un
voto 6 più cioè non è stato possibile
insomma a metterti veramente non lo
sapeva troppo bravi educare i nostri
figli
a questi due bravissimi ragazzi hanno
appena pubblicato un libro per mondatori
che si chiama un figlio ho detto tutto
quindi andato a leggere prendetelo in
libreria lo trovi ovunque
distribuiremo il verbo e bloccheremo la
produzione di figli in italia 8 a dallas
e mezza per ora di prendere tutto è ok
nè stasera uccidendo i se non ti
dispiace
ok che non volevi aprire la nostra
famiglia